when I was in high school half my
wardrobe would have been like not
allowed hi my name is Salani and i've
been a teacher for five years my name is
Stephanie and I've been a teacher for
three years hi my name is Ted I've been
a teacher for five years my name is Ryan
and I've been a substitute teacher for
two years and today we're going to talk
about real or fake dress codes it just
depends on the situation you know
sometimes it's really hot some of the
kids will take certain things off and
I'm okay with it and then there's some
people that do things for attention in
my experience with dress code I find
myself to be lenient unless it's like
over you know they're showing up in like
a t-shirt with like bad words written on
it's like I think it's part of being a
teenager sometimes with your try to get
attention from what you wear if I see
something particularly egregious then
maybe I'll like let another teacher know
and be like hey is this something that's
should be like mentioned but other than
that I mean as long as it's not
something like wildly inappropriate like
I'm not gonna fight about it
out of drede specified be I say a
because she has a shirt that's it's not
short to me but it's short enough to
wear maybe if she lifted her arms up her
stomach might show I'm gonna say I'm
gonna go with B being inappropriate just
because the shirt maybe use a little
low-cut I don't know there's like a
zipper on it or something that's kind of
like maybe suggestive I don't know it
doesn't bother me but I don't go to
school in Georgia yeah I want to have to
agree I want to say B is inappropriate
there's a lot of skin more skin that I
would expect yeah
B B
[Music]
Oh Georgia you never be going to do what
I would have been out of joist code what
the shirt must extend to the top of the
knees so they're supposed to wear like a
quadruple XL I did not even realize that
were leggings I just presume that a was
very skinny you know I'm like I'm gonna
say a because of the nose ring you know
I'm gonna say it cuz I hope it they oh
well I feel like this is there's a trick
here you know what I'm gonna say a I'm
gonna say a to why do you think so
I think a isn't appropriate because I
see some piercing in the nose the nose
ring I feel like there's this is the
trapdoor here I would also find it hard
pressed for a school like to have
written into their like you know their
bylaws or whatever they're like Oh
makeup can be weird but only by a female
maybe maybe I'm being you know naive in
that sense
[Music]
how would have been kicked out of school
haha if that was a rule at my school
I'll say you look great let me get a
picture of you first take a go to the
bathroom wipe that off and then come
back I wish I could just let him wear it
but I know I'm kind of the same boat
what come on
for two here we go
[Music]
Oh a girl showing her shoulders I was
thinking but dang yeah but a guy can
wear your shoulders out oh that's so
unfair I don't know either way it's
unfair I say both be I'll say because
it's a girl yeah Rob ibly gonna say that
the underarm is too close I don't know
so they're both tattooed both wearing
the same shirt same same color hair even
one is a man and one is a woman okay I
think that might play into their dress
code here Oh tough this guys have got a
nose ring - that's have a nose ring okay
they both everything's the same so I
think saying we have tattoos okay I'm
gonna say a and I want to say a because
I think that this school may participate
in the same dress code that you see in
some of those fancy clubs that are like
no athletic wear men have to wear long
sleeve button-down shirts or something
like that and tank tops would be
inappropriate for a man but okay for a
woman I'm gonna go with a as well
but guys can wear their arms out I had
that rule as a middle school student
here in California and I got in trouble
for it yeah but that was you know 15
years ago so I had it like good just a
thin tank top and I always got in
trouble and boys would walk around just
like freestyling in nice and cool yeah I
don't know I feel like they both look
awesome so why would you all have one
and not the other
[Music]
I'm gonna say a good say yeah just
because you can see a little bit of her
stomach
it's a v-neck but he can get away with
wearing baggy pants though or a little
bit wrinkled they should say no wrinkles
no wrinkles
he's wearing a t-shirt that is untucked
oh and she is wearing a white shirt that
it's too short to be tough yeah I do see
a little bit of skin in between the
shirt and the pants there how do I say
be and I'm gonna say be because I think
that the t-shirt for guys is a no-no I'm
gonna go with a because I do see a
little bit of like that skin in between
the shirt and the pants and you know I
mean monterrey pretty progressive place
I would imagine but I have to choose the
opposite of him so I'm going with it
right
[Music]
I'm so confused why maybe it references
games I don't know I mean that's a good
guy it looks like a hobby he's like hey
Hollywood California yeah I wouldn't
care but if I had to enforce that I
would say look can you go turn your
shirt inside out the principal's coming
to check and then as soon as they left
I'd be like Jim you go put it back
regular I don't know why don't you say
that yeah
fire I would enforce it with an eye roll
Wow congratulate
it what oh but only California so if
this person was wearing like a big star
of Texas t-shirt they would have that
would be totally fine
[Music]
I already know it hey you know man hey
it's not even the man but it's cuz he
has dreads and I'm sure that they're
gonna say something or brains or
something yeah it's cuz he has twists
and I feel like they're gonna say that
he's not allowed to have no there's
something crazy I was thinking yeah I
was thinking the hairstyle so let's say
we have two people - nose rings - buns
his button contains you know like
braided hair her as dozen I don't know
if that's gonna make you know a problem
that looks like an earring it looks like
a like a shell or something attached to
his ear I'm going to say a and the
reason I'm saying a is because I think
that this part of Texas might have a
specific rule about hair length per man
I'm thinking kind of the same thing they
would probably I mean maybe in Texas
they have some sort of stricter
requirement for hair or something
[Music]
but girls can wear buttons I would feel
sad to enforce the rule I probably would
get in trouble I'd fight with them
because you know some cultures I have
students that are from certain places
that they grow their hair long so they
have to wear it up I would let them
slide the principal would have to come
and check me yes oh my god one points
let the man bones free you know yeah
we're here to say it I feel like a
little frustrated it's so outdated yeah
it's it's hard to believe it definitely
makes me a little angry
oh it's annoying I would fight for my
students if they have you know certain
things that they can't change like or if
it's super hot and a girl can't wear a
tank top Oh God come on what are we in
like 1922 or something yeah it's weird
I mean all of these came as a surprise
to me in the first place so it's totally
than the realm of possibility that I
would be teaching in a school and then
be surprised that a student was in my
class that wasn't following the dress
code I do think that when it comes to
dress codes and don't like the Wild West
you have no there's no real way to like
be able to guess without looking at the
three page single-spaced document with
some admin typed up to be like this we
have to make sure that they don't they
their show their shoulder straps should
be wide
[Music]